This episode is brought to you by Redfin. You're listening to a podcast, which means you're probably multitasking, maybe even scrolling home listings on Redfin, saving homes without expecting to get them. But Redfin isn't just built for endless browsing. It's built to help you find and own a home. With agents who close twice as many deals, when you find the one, you've got a real shot at getting it. Get started at Redfin.com. Own the dream.
本期节目由 Redfin 赞助播出。您正在收听播客，这意味着您可能正在一心多用，甚至可能在 Redfin 上浏览房源，收藏着那些并不指望能买到的房子。但 Redfin 不仅仅是为了无休止的浏览而设计的，它是为了帮助您找到并拥有一个家。我们的经纪人成交量是普通经纪人的两倍，当您找到心仪的房子时，您将有更大的把握将其收入囊中。请访问 Redfin.com 开始您的旅程。拥有梦想。
Hello, and welcome to Speaking of Cyclone. a bi-weekly podcast from the American Psychological Association. I'm your host, Caitlin Luna. Before we start, I want to remind you that if you have any comments, questions, or ideas for us, please email me at K-Luna at APA.org. That's K-L-U-N-A-A-A-D-R. Now on to the conversation. Anxiety among teens and young adults is rising, and studies have shown that it is
您好，欢迎收听《Speaking of Psychology》，这是美国心理学会推出的一档双周播客。我是主持人凯特琳·卢纳（Caitlin Luna）。在开始之前，我想提醒大家，如果您有任何意见、问题或想法，请发送电子邮件至 K-Luna@APA.org。即 K-L-U-N-A-A-A-D-R。现在，让我们进入今天的对话。青少年和年轻人的焦虑情绪正在上升，研究表明，这种现象在女孩中
skyrocketed in girls. One study found that the number of girls who often felt nervous, worried, or fearful jumped by 55% over a five-year period. What factors are behind rising stress and anxiety in girls, and what can we do about it? Our guest for this episode is Dr. Lisa DeMore, a clinical psychologist and executive director of Laurel School's Center for Research on Girls. She has a new book out now called Under Pressure, Confronting the Epidemic of Stress and Anxiety and Girls.
呈激增趋势。一项研究发现，在五年内，经常感到紧张、担忧或恐惧的女孩人数增加了 55%。女孩压力和焦虑增加背后的因素是什么？我们又能做些什么呢？本期节目的嘉宾是临床心理学家、劳雷尔学校女孩研究中心（Laurel School's Center for Research on Girls）执行主任丽莎·达莫尔（Dr. Lisa Damour）博士。她最近出版了一本新书，名为《压力之下：直面女孩的压力与焦虑流行病》（Under Pressure: Confronting the Epidemic of Stress and Anxiety in Girls）。
Dr. DeMore also writes a monthly column about adolescence for the New York Times. Welcome, Dr. DeMore. Thanks so much for having me. We're delighted to have you with us. In your book, you get right to the point in the introduction when you write, something has changed. Anxiety has always been a part of life growing up, but in recent years, it seems to have spun out of control. What are you seeing in your practice and in your work with the school and as the mother of two daughters?
达莫尔博士还为《纽约时报》撰写关于青春期的月度专栏。欢迎您，达莫尔博士。非常感谢您的邀请。我们很高兴您能来到这里。在您的书中，您在引言中直截了当地写道：“有些事情已经改变了。”焦虑一直是成长过程中生活的一部分，但近年来，它似乎已经失控了。在您的临床实践、学校工作以及作为两个女儿的母亲的经历中，您看到了什么？
So it's interesting. What I have noticed, I would say, kind of around the last 10 years, is that the general population talks about anxiety a lot more, talks about stress a lot more and talks about both as if they were always into everywhere pathological, that there was no healthy form. Whereas we, of course, as psychologists know that anxiety and stress are normal and healthy functions that can reach, you know, pathological levels, but they really are sort of a part of daily life. And so that sort of change in kind of the popular discourse really caught my ear. A lot of, you know, girls sort of showing up in my practice or coming to see me at the school
这很有趣。我想说，在大约过去 10 年里，我注意到大众对焦虑谈论得更多了，对压力也谈论得更多了，而且谈论两者时，就好像它们总是无处不在的病理现象，仿佛不存在健康的焦虑形式。然而，我们作为心理学家当然知道，焦虑和压力是正常且健康的机能，虽然它们可能达到病理水平，但它们确实是日常生活的一部分。因此，这种大众话语的转变引起了我的注意。很多女孩出现在我的诊所，或者在学校来看我，
where I consult two days a week and popping down in my chair in front of me and saying, I have anxiety and talking about it as if it were a life sentence and something that they were stuck with indefinitely where, you know, I always have to sort of be careful about how I respond because part of me wants to say, well, of course you have anxiety. You're awake. You got out of bed. And so I do feel like one of the things that has changed is that there is a misunderstanding. And we are taking care of a population of adults and young people, and my focus is especially on girls who are anxious about being anxious.
（我在那里每周咨询两天），她们坐在我面前的椅子上说：“我有焦虑症”，并谈论它，就好像这是一种终身监禁，一种她们无法摆脱的状态。你知道，我总是必须小心回应，因为我内心想说：“好吧，你当然有焦虑。你醒着，你从床上爬起来了。”所以我确实觉得改变的一点是，存在一种误解。我们正在照顾一群成年人和年轻人，而我特别关注那些对“焦虑”本身感到焦虑的女孩。
and my suspicion is that has helped to push the rates up a little bit because if you're going to feel anxiety in the course of a normal day, which you really are, and then you also feel anxious about being anxious, that cannot, you know, that can't be a good thing. I think there are other factors at play besides the sort of misunderstanding or the disconnect between our sort of clinical and academic understanding of anxiety and the popular culture's understanding of anxiety. and the popular culture's understanding of anxiety. I think for girls in particular, over time, we have just gradually added more and more to their plates, but we've taken nothing off their plates. Girls are incredibly good students. They are really outpacing boys academically.
我的怀疑是，这在一定程度上推高了焦虑率。因为如果你在正常的一天中感到焦虑（这确实会发生），然后你又因为感到焦虑而感到焦虑，那这绝对不是一件好事。我认为除了这种误解，或者说我们临床和学术界对焦虑的理解与大众文化对焦虑的理解之间的脱节之外，还有其他因素在起作用。我认为对于女孩来说，随着时间的推移，我们给她们增加的负担越来越多，却从未减少过。女孩是非常优秀的学生。她们在学业上确实超过了男孩。
At this point, one statistic is that they are 70% of high school valedictorians. Wow. They're accomplishing things that, you know, In some ways, there's never been a better time to be a girl. You know, there's so many opportunities, so much access for them. And yet, you know, they still worry about how they look. They're still told by the culture to worry about how they look. We still have expectations that girls will be agreeable and polite.
目前，有一个统计数据是，她们占高中毕业典礼致辞学生（valedictorians）的 70%。哇。她们取得的成就……你知道，在某些方面，现在是女孩最好的时代。你知道，她们有太多的机会，太多的获取资源的途径。然而，你知道，她们仍然担心自己的外表。文化仍然告诉她们要担心自己的外表。我们仍然期望女孩要随和、有礼貌。
Go to their brother's soccer games, if that's sort of the family program. And I think about, you know, there's boys are doing less well in school than they should, but there are a lot of boys who are doing quite well in school, and they're working very hard. And I just know they're not spending as much time as the girls are worrying about if they look good enough. You know, so I think that that's a factor among others. So I think there's that, there's the speeding up of the culture, thanks to technology. I've started to think about it in terms of how much content everybody absorbs in a day now.
如果那是家庭安排，她们还得去参加兄弟的足球比赛。我想到，你知道，男孩在学校的表现不如他们应该表现的那样好，但也有很多男孩在学校表现得相当不错，他们也非常努力。我只是知道，他们花在担心自己看起来是否足够好上的时间，并没有女孩那么多。所以，我认为这是诸多因素中的一个。我认为还有文化加速的原因，这要归功于技术。我开始从每个人每天吸收的内容量来思考这个问题。
adults and young people, and that, you know, with sort of 24-hour constant access to basically the whole world and its news updates, we're taking in a lot of information. And I think, you know, I know there are psychologists really trying to sort out how much can we take in in a day and still, you know, be operating at healthy levels. So, you know, you spoke a lot about how culture plays a role and the pressures that girls are facing. Can you talk a little bit more about what girls face with their friends, with members of the opposite sex? And, you know, as they're trying to achieve, what sort of messages are they telling themselves? So, you know, it's interesting. If we think about the culture and friends and, you know, gendered relationships, you know, how girls interact with boys. there are stresses sort of built into this. And in my work, and certainly in this book under pressure,
成年人和年轻人，你知道，随着对整个世界及其新闻更新的 24 小时持续访问，我们正在摄入大量信息。我认为，我知道有心理学家真的在试图弄清楚我们每天能摄入多少信息，同时还能保持在健康的水平上运作。所以，你谈了很多关于文化如何发挥作用以及女孩面临的压力。你能多谈谈女孩在朋友、异性面前面临的问题吗？而且，当她们试图取得成就时，她们在对自己说什么？所以，这很有趣。如果我们思考文化、朋友和性别关系，你知道，女孩如何与男孩互动，这些压力是内置的。在我的工作中，当然还有这本《压力之下》中，
you know, I try to address these stresses from a few sides. You know, one is to say, look, stress is going to happen, anxiety is going to happen. These are normal healthy functions. And even when they cross over a line into unhealthy, we're really good at treating them. You know, and this is true. Like there's, you know, I would say that probably a lot of psychologists would agree that if we look at the DSM-5 in terms of the, you know, the diagnoses that we feel like we've really got a pretty good handle on, I bet, you know, anxiety would be very high on that list and even stress disorders where, you know, we're getting better and better at managing those, and we actually have more difficulty treating other things.
我试图从几个方面来解决这些压力。一方面是说，看，压力会发生，焦虑会发生。这些是正常健康的机能。即使当它们越界变成不健康时，我们也擅长治疗它们。这是真的。我想说，可能很多心理学家会同意，如果我们查看《精神疾病诊断与统计手册第 5 版》（DSM-5），看看那些我们觉得已经相当了解的诊断，我敢说，焦虑会排在名单的前列，甚至包括压力障碍，我们处理这些问题的能力越来越强，而我们处理其他事情反而更困难。
But then also within the book, what I aim to do, and when I'm thinking about young people, is to then take seriously the stresses they do face and make sure. that adults are responding in the most useful ways possible to those stresses. So you mentioned with friends, you know, I think that one of the, one of the things that adults have sort of been slow to appreciate is that conflict is going to happen among young people. Conflict happens among people, you know, all the time. It just is, again, like waking up, you know, if you're going to be in a room with someone for a while and both people are conscious, you know, eventually there will probably be a conflict. Right. And then if you take 30 people and you put them in a room and you make them be
但在书中，我的目标是，当我想到年轻人时，认真对待她们面临的压力，并确保成年人以最有效的方式应对这些压力。所以你提到了朋友，我认为成年人一直比较迟钝的一点是，年轻人之间必然会发生冲突。人与人之间一直都会发生冲突。这就像醒来一样，如果你和某人待在一个房间里一段时间，而且两人都是清醒的，那么最终很可能会发生冲突。没错。如果你把 30 个人放在一个房间里，让他们每天整天待在一起，
together all day every day and you do that for nine months, you know, there's going to be conflict and that's school. And so I think we have not done yet enough to help people become very adept at managing conflict. I spent two days a week consulting in a school and I visit a lot of schools. And I think in a really well-meaning way, you know, our efforts around conflict often come down to us saying, you know, hey, we want you guys to get along. And if you're not going to get along, we want you to respect each other, which isn't a lot to go on. And so one of the things I worked to unpack in my writing, you know, is how do we teach kids to do conflict well? And how do we teach them, you know, what are the unhealthy forms of conflict and what are some healthy forms?
持续九个月，肯定会有冲突，这就是学校。所以我认为我们还没有做足够的工作来帮助人们变得非常擅长管理冲突。我每周在学校咨询两天，我参观过很多学校。我认为，出于好意，我们围绕冲突所做的努力往往归结为我们说：“嘿，我们希望你们能和睦相处。如果你们不能和睦相处，我们希望你们互相尊重。”这并没有提供太多实质性的指导。所以我写作中试图拆解的一点是，我们如何教孩子处理好冲突？我们如何教她们什么是病态的冲突形式，什么是健康的冲突形式？
And how do we provide really meaningful guidance on it? And I think the reason that adults have largely not done this is that adults are usually not so great at dealing with conflict. And so then it's hard for us to teach kids what the things that we're not really fluent in ourselves. So I think that those are some of the social stressors, which is that kids are having and girls are having expectable conflicts, but they don't really have a repertoire for managing them. Yeah, and it is very challenging. It's obviously some people are conflict avoidant, some people seek it out. And so as adults, like you said, How are we going to lead by example if we struggle with it ourselves? I mean, you see it play out in the adult world all the time.
我们如何提供真正有意义的指导？我认为成年人大多没有这样做，是因为成年人通常也不太擅长处理冲突。所以，我们很难教给孩子我们自己都不太精通的东西。所以我认为这些是一些社会压力源，即孩子们，特别是女孩，正在经历预料之中的冲突，但她们并没有一套管理冲突的技能。是的，这非常有挑战性。显然，有些人回避冲突，有些人寻求冲突。所以作为成年人，就像你说的，如果我们自己都在挣扎，我们该如何以身作则？我的意思是，你在成人世界里一直都能看到这种情况。
Absolutely. And I actually picked up along the way this fabulous set of metaphors from some teachers to teach conflict. And it works really well. So when I talk with young people, I say, look, there's three unhealthy forms of conflict. There's being a bulldozer, you know, running people over. There's being a doormat, which is just letting yourself get run over. And there's being a dormant with spikes, which is far in a way the most common form for both adults. and kids, which is basically passive-aggressive behaviors, you know, using guilt as a weapon or playing
绝对是这样。我实际上在过程中从一些老师那里学到了一套很棒的隐喻来教授冲突。它非常有效。所以当我和年轻人交谈时，我说，看，有三种不健康的冲突形式。一种是“推土机”，你知道，横冲直撞；一种是“门垫”，就是任由自己被践踏；还有一种是“带刺的门垫”，这是成年人和孩子中最常见的一种，基本上就是被动攻击行为，你知道，利用内疚作为武器，或者扮演
the part of a victim or involving third parties in what should be like really a one-on-one discussion. And then I talk with them about how the healthiest form of conflict is to be a pillar, you know, to stand up for yourself while being respectful of other people. And these, you know, young people latch on to these metaphors really quickly. It makes me mean. sense to them, and it gives them a framework for thinking about how they may be inclined to react, because most people start by reacting in one of the unhealthy forms, and how they truly want to act if they decide to take up a conflict. That's really wonderful metaphor for how to approach conflict. I really like that. I think I might keep that in my back pocket for another time.
受害者的角色，或者在应该是一对一讨论的事情中引入第三方。然后我告诉她们，最健康的冲突形式是成为一根“柱子”，你知道，在尊重他人的同时坚持自己的立场。这些年轻人很快就记住了这些隐喻。这对她们来说很有意义，它为她们提供了一个框架，让她们思考自己倾向于如何反应（因为大多数人开始时都会以某种不健康的形式反应），以及如果她们决定处理冲突，她们真正想采取的行动。这对于如何处理冲突来说是一个非常棒的隐喻。我真的很喜欢。我想我可能会把它记下来，留作以后使用。
It works. It works. Yeah, it's a really wonderful way to describe it. So, you know, is a way to just keep yourself to hold yourself to a high standard and also understand that you, have the right to stand up for yourself. You do. And the other thing, though, I will also add is you also have the right to do nothing. I, especially with the time I spend with kids, I've become aware that adults tend to encourage kids to take up every conflict. Oh, she hurt your feelings.
它很管用。是的，这确实是一种非常棒的描述方式。所以，这是一种让自己保持高标准，同时也明白你有权坚持自己立场的方式。确实如此。不过，我还要补充一点，你也有权什么都不做。我，特别是在我与孩子相处的时间里，我意识到成年人倾向于鼓励孩子去处理每一个冲突。哦，她伤害了你的感情。
You need to say something to her. You know, oh, you know, he left you out of something. You need to let him know you were hurt. And I think sometimes that makes a lot of sense. but I think in truth, no adult, no functioning adult, is engaging every annoyance in the day. That we are all day long making very tactical decisions about, you know, conscious or not, about, you know, how much do I care about this relationship that I need to repair that problem with a person? How likely do I think it is that if I bring up this conflict with someone, they're going to handle it well?
你需要对她说些什么。你知道，哦，他把你排除在外了。你需要让他知道你受伤了。我认为有时这很有道理，但事实上，没有一个功能正常的成年人会去处理每天遇到的每一个烦恼。我们整天都在做非常策略性的决定，无论是有意识还是无意识的，关于我有多在乎这段关系，以至于需要去修复那个问题？如果我向某人提出这个冲突，他们处理得好的可能性有多大？
And if I pillar it, are they going to pillar back? You know, all of those things. Am I better off just sort of maintaining a polite distance from this person? And so I also think as we help kids learn to navigate conflict, we have to put right on the table next to pilloring the possibility of what I call emotional Aikido, right? And I've heard other therapists call it this too, where in Aikido, this form of martial arts, if someone comes at you, the first thing you do is you just step out of the way.
如果我像“柱子”一样坚持立场，他们会以同样的方式回应吗？你知道，所有这些事情。我是不是最好与这个人保持礼貌的距离？所以我也认为，当我们帮助孩子学习如何应对冲突时，我们必须把“情感合气道”的可能性放在“柱子”旁边，对吧？我也听过其他治疗师这样称呼它，在合气道这种武术中，如果有人向你冲过来，你做的第一件事就是侧身避开。
You just sort of let them go right on past. And a lot of drama does die. from lack of attentional oxygen. And I think sometimes in our well-meaning way, when we're saying to kids, you need to let her know she hurt your feelings, we may actually be fueling something that didn't really, was never going to be resolved
你只是让他们直接从你身边过去。很多戏剧性的冲突确实会因为缺乏关注的“氧气”而消亡。我认为有时出于好意，当我们对孩子说“你需要让她知道她伤害了你的感情”时，我们实际上可能是在助长某种永远无法解决的事情，
and that the girl didn't even care that much about the relationship to want to try to work on it. Right. That's a really great pathways to resolving conflict. So do anxiety, and stress and girls need to be treated differently than it would be in boys? Probably not. You know, and I think that one of the rules that we know as psychologists is that fundamentally, boys and girls are more alike, men and women are more alike than they are different. And we do see
而且那个女孩甚至并不那么在乎这段关系，不想尝试去修复它。没错。这确实是解决冲突的绝佳途径。那么，女孩的焦虑和压力是否需要与男孩区别对待？可能不需要。我认为我们作为心理学家知道的规则之一是，从根本上讲，男孩和女孩的相似之处多于不同之处，男人和女人的相似之处多于不同之处。我们确实看到
high rates of anxiety and girls. You know, this is a long established finding, you know, because the other thing we know is that when girls are in distress, they tend to internalize. When boys are in distress, they tend to externalize. But if I'm sitting with an anxious client, my bag of tricks is pretty much the same for boys and girls. I think that what I'm of interest, you know, a particular interest to me and what I'm writing about is that probably the causes of the stress and anxiety are not totally the same for boys and girls. That they are each, you know, there's certainly a great degree of overlap, but there are also some very unique stressors to. being a boy in our culture and being a girl in our culture.
女孩的焦虑率很高。这是一个长期确立的发现，因为我们知道的另一件事是，当女孩感到痛苦时，她们倾向于内化。当男孩感到痛苦时，他们倾向于外化。但如果我面对的是一个焦虑的客户，我的“锦囊妙计”对男孩和女孩来说基本是一样的。我认为让我感兴趣的是，我正在写的是，压力和焦虑的起因对于男孩和女孩来说可能并不完全相同。它们确实有很大程度的重叠，但作为我们文化中的男孩和女孩，也有一些非常独特的压力源。
So those groups need to be addressed appropriately. But you said how you treat it would be basically the same. I mean tailored to each person, but similar. I think that's right. And I think, again, you know, anxiety is kind of like smoke. You know, there's fire underneath it. And so, you know, we're good at treating the smoke. We're good at helping people manage their emotional reaction.
所以这些群体需要得到适当的对待。但你说治疗方式基本相同。我的意思是针对每个人进行调整，但相似。我认为是对的。而且我认为，焦虑就像烟雾。下面有火。所以，我们擅长处理烟雾。我们擅长帮助人们管理他们的情绪反应，
to things that make them feel very, very anxious. And I think our tools for treating anxiety are established and they work well and we're good at it. I'm interested in the fires. So whether it's the pressures on girls about how they look or the ways in which girls, I think, sometimes are over-exerting themselves at school and nobody stops them. you know, some various are gender-specific sources of anxiety. And I'm interested in what we can do as a culture to address those before they become a problem for girls, you know, or to give girls strategies for managing the strains that come
对那些让他们感到非常非常焦虑的事情。我认为我们治疗焦虑的工具已经成熟，它们运作良好，我们也很擅长。我对“火”感兴趣。所以，无论是女孩在外表上面临的压力，还是我认为女孩有时在学校过度劳累而没有人阻止她们，你知道，一些性别特有的焦虑来源。我感兴趣的是，作为一个文化，我们能做些什么来在这些问题成为女孩的困扰之前解决它们，或者给女孩提供管理这些压力的策略，
with being female in this culture so that they are not trying to navigate those alone. Absolutely. And your book is full of advice for parents of teen girls. And so what are the biggest takeaways parents need to know? Well, I think one thing that I find very reassuring is that how parents react to stress and anxiety goes a long way to dictating what happens next. And for me, I think the best metaphor, the best moment in parenting, the time when parents really tend to get this right is when you're parenting a toddler who scrapes her knee or his knee. You know, there's a very distinct pattern of what occurs. You know, the toddler falls down, scrapes their knee, and then they look at their knee, and then they look at the parent's face. And what is going on on the parent's face is really going to shape the rest of the, you know, the rest of the interaction.
作为这个文化中的女性，这样她们就不会试图独自应对这些压力。绝对是这样。你的书里充满了给青少年女孩父母的建议。那么父母需要知道的最大收获是什么？嗯，我认为我发现非常令人欣慰的一点是，父母对压力和焦虑的反应在很大程度上决定了接下来会发生什么。对我来说，我认为最好的隐喻，育儿中最好的时刻，是当父母真正做对的时候，那就是当你抚养一个擦伤膝盖的幼儿时。你知道，发生的事情有一个非常独特的模式。幼儿摔倒，擦伤膝盖，然后他们看着自己的膝盖，然后看着父母的脸。父母脸上的表情真的会决定接下来互动的发展。
If the parent is stricken and panicking, that is usually pretty scary to the kid and they sort of fall apart. If the parent, even if they are feeling stricken and panicking on the inside, if the parent sort of can maintain their composure and say, oh, ouch, you know, let's go get you inside and get you cleaned up. Usually the kid's like, okay, you know, and sort of takes it from there. And so my aim in writing under pressure was both to try to do a little bit of a public service announcement about anxiety and stress being normal and healthy and manageable when they're not. And then also to articulate all sorts of things that adults can do to help make things better. And so one really key one is for adults to manage their own stress and anxiety. sufficiently, that when they are faced with a young person who's feeling very, very stressed or very, very anxious, they can summon what abounds to a containing response, you know,
如果父母感到震惊和恐慌，这对孩子来说通常很可怕，他们会崩溃。如果父母，即使内心感到震惊和恐慌，也能保持镇定并说：“哦，哎哟，来，我们进去清理一下。”通常孩子会说：“好吧。”然后继续做别的事。所以我写《压力之下》的目标，既是试图做一个关于焦虑和压力是正常、健康且在非病理状态下可控的公益广告，也是为了阐明成年人可以做的各种事情，以帮助改善情况。所以一个非常关键的点是，成年人要充分管理好自己的压力和焦虑，
not dismissive, not invalidating, not minimizing, but a sort of a confidence that, yeah, wow, you know, your knee looks kind of bloody. Yes, that does seem like a very big test. I'm here to help you through it. You're going to get through it. We'll figure this out. You'll figure this out. Those kinds of reactions make a very big difference for parents.
这样当他们面对一个感到非常非常紧张或焦虑的年轻人时，他们就能召唤出一种“包容性”的回应，不是轻视，不是否定，不是最小化，而是一种自信，即“是的，哇，你的膝盖看起来确实流血了。是的，这看起来确实是一个很大的考验。我在这里帮你度过难关。你会挺过去的。我们会解决这个问题的。你会解决这个问题的。”这些反应对父母来说有很大的不同。
We've talked a few times already about the importance of leading by example. So what are some of other ways parents can lead by example for their teens in terms of whether it's watching their time on their cell phones or in front of a screen or if it's about going to sleep earlier? How can parents do that a little bit better? Well, I'm so glad you brought up sleep and technology because I think, you know, if you, you know, if you said, like, what are, like, what's really making kids fragile these days? I think one of the lowest hanging fruits, one of the simplest explanations is they just get nowhere near as much sleep as they need. You know, and I think there's also a lot of misunderstanding about how much sleep kids need. Most parents will say, I think they need about eight hours. That's not actually true. Elementary school
我们已经谈了几次以身作则的重要性。那么，父母在青少年面前以身作则的其他方式有哪些？无论是控制手机使用时间、屏幕时间，还是早点睡觉。父母如何能做得更好？嗯，我很高兴你提到了睡眠和技术，因为我认为，如果你说“到底是什么让现在的孩子变得脆弱？”，我认为最容易实现的目标之一，最简单的解释就是他们得到的睡眠远没有他们需要的那么多。而且我认为对于孩子需要多少睡眠也存在很多误解。大多数父母会说：“我想他们需要大约八小时。”这其实是不对的。小学
kids need around 11 hours on average. Middle school kids need about 10 hours on average, and then high schoolers need nine, you know, which is much more than most get. Absolutely, yeah. Right. And, you know, we've studied sleep up, down and sideways, and we know that it is, you know, the summary headline is it's the glue that holds human beings together. And so one thing parents can do is to model really good habits around sleep and especially around technology and sleep. So easy fixes or simple fixes. They may not always be easy to implement are things from as severe As, you know, one of my friends, I love this, has a rule in her house that no technology goes to the second floor of the home ever. And that's where the bedrooms are in their house. Other people I know have a rule that no technology ever crosses the threshold of a bedroom at any point in the 24-hour day. You know, that just that is not allowed. Other families, you know, sometimes there are teenagers who do a really good job of studying in their room with their technology.
孩子平均需要大约 11 小时。初中生平均需要大约 10 小时，高中生需要 9 小时，这比大多数人得到的要多得多。绝对是这样。没错。我们对睡眠进行了全方位的研究，我们知道它是人类凝聚在一起的“胶水”。所以父母能做的一件事就是树立良好的睡眠习惯，特别是在技术和睡眠方面。所以简单的修复方法，虽然实施起来可能并不总是那么容易，比如像我的一位朋友，我喜欢这个规则，她家里的规则是技术设备永远不能上二楼，那是他们家卧室所在的地方。我认识的其他人规定，在 24 小时的任何时候，技术设备都不得跨越卧室的门槛。你知道，这是不允许的。其他家庭，有时有些青少年在房间里使用技术设备学习做得很好。
So I think for those families, a really good rule. rule is that's fine, but the second, you know, by a certain point in the night, it has to come out, you know, that it can't stay in the room overnight. So things like that, especially when they're laid down early. I think sometimes it's hard to walk these back if bad habits have been established. Right. Yeah, absolutely. But it's, you know, it's not that hard to convince, you know, a nine-year-old that they cannot take technology into their bedroom. And so I think once that's established, and also when parents model it. And it's funny because I know, and this may be in places where the quarters are very, very close, or kids need to be very, very carefully supervised. I know some families
所以我认为对于那些家庭来说，一个很好的规则是，这没问题，但到了晚上某个时间点，它必须拿出来，它不能在房间里过夜。所以像这样的事情，特别是当它们很早就被设定好时。我认为如果已经养成了坏习惯，有时很难扭转。没错。是的，绝对是。但说服一个九岁的孩子不要把技术设备带进卧室并不难。所以我认为一旦确立了这一点，而且当父母也这样做时。很有趣，因为我知道，这可能是在空间非常非常狭小，或者孩子需要非常非常仔细监督的地方。我知道有些家庭
make a rule where the parents charge all the technology in their room overnight. You know, they get a power strip and they charge it in their bedroom. And I think this is a great strategy if you really need to know that your kid isn't sneaking out of their room to get a little extra time. But I would say, gosh, if you can actually model that it doesn't go in a bedroom, that would be my first choice. And that it really is divorced from resting and sleeping and that part of our lives that we do not do nearly enough to protect. And you really want to touch on what you said in a recent CBS this morning interview where you did talk about screen time. And in that interview you talked about, and I thought this was a really beautiful way to put it, about that limiting screen time is not a, about deprivation, it's about preserving what's important, whether that's family time, hobbies,
规定父母在晚上把所有的技术设备放在他们的房间充电。他们买一个电源板，在他们的卧室里充电。我认为如果你真的需要知道你的孩子没有偷偷溜出房间去多玩一会儿，这是一个很好的策略。但我会说，天哪，如果你真的能以身作则，不把设备带进卧室，那将是我的首选。它确实应该与休息和睡眠分开，这是我们生活中没有得到足够保护的部分。你真的想谈谈你在最近的《CBS 今晨》采访中所说的话，当时你确实谈到了屏幕时间。在那个采访中，你谈到了，我认为这是一个非常优美的表达方式，限制屏幕时间不是关于剥夺，而是关于保护重要的东西，无论是家庭时间、爱好、
sleep, whatever it is. It's about protecting those things and not necessarily about depriving and taking away technology from yourself as a parent or for the teen. That's right. You know, it's interesting. You know, there's a lot of interest in what the data are going to say about how technology shapes childhood or, you know, alters the adolescent brain. And I mean, we're psychologists. We know these studies are going to take a long time to come in. They're going to be pretty murky in their findings. You know, it's very hard to do good longitudinal research that is going to pinpoint. It takes a lot of time. So I sort of feel like, well, while we wait for the data to come in, let's go with what we know. And what we know is that there are essential elements of life that are critical to healthy development in children.
睡眠，还是其他任何东西。这是关于保护这些东西，而不一定是为了剥夺或从你自己作为父母或青少年手中拿走技术。没错。很有趣。人们对数据将如何说明技术如何塑造童年或改变青少年大脑非常感兴趣。我的意思是，我们是心理学家。我们知道这些研究需要很长时间才能得出结果。它们的发现会非常模糊。进行能够精确定位的良好纵向研究非常困难。这需要很多时间。所以我有点觉得，好吧，在我们等待数据出来的时候，让我们根据我们所知道的去做。我们所知道的是，生活中存在对儿童健康发展至关重要的基本要素。
So getting enough sleep, hugely important part of healthy development. Having one-on-one, or not even one-on-one, face-to-face contact, learning social skills through practicing social skills, through reading social cues, for learning how to do that, hugely important. You know, meals where people are talking, you know, uninterrupted time with people who love you. Physical exercise, you know, physical activity is important. And then this, we could talk about a great length, but I'll just sum it up, studying without unnecessary interruption. Right? We know everything we need to know about human attention and what it means to disrupt it and how much time is lost, even if you're interrupting yourself, you know, what interruptions do to concentration, what they do to accuracy, what they do to speed of work. So we know all of these things. So I think it's most useful when parents say to their, you know, to young people, look, I'm not against technology. I am for sleep. I am for, you know, face-to-face conversations. I am for you getting your homework done in a focused, concentrated, way. I am for you, you know, being up and about moving your body. So why don't we make sure all of
所以获得充足的睡眠，是健康发展中极其重要的一部分。拥有面对面的接触，通过练习社交技能、阅读社交线索来学习社交技能，学习如何做到这一点，极其重要。你知道，人们交谈的用餐时间，与爱你的人在一起的不间断时间。体育锻炼，身体活动很重要。然后这一点，我们可以详细讨论，但我总结一下，没有不必要干扰的学习。对吧？我们知道关于人类注意力的一切，以及打断它意味着什么，以及损失了多少时间，即使是你自己在打断自己，你知道，干扰对专注力有什么影响，对准确性有什么影响，对工作速度有什么影响。所以我们知道所有这些事情。所以我认为，当父母对年轻人说：“看，我不反对技术。我支持睡眠。我支持面对面的交谈。我支持你以专注的方式完成家庭作业。我支持你起床活动身体。”这是最有用的。所以为什么我们不确保所有
those things are happening as much as they need to be happening? And then we'll look at the time that's left. And some of that certainly can go to technology. And obviously social media plays a big role in this. And in that same interview, you were asked about what's causing teen depression, anxiety, and suicide rates. And again, I thought your answer was really very interesting and wonderful. You said, simple answers are appealing, but they're probably not accurate. So we need to take a broad look at the issue. Can you elaborate on that a little bit more? Yeah.
这些事情都在按需要发生呢？然后我们再看看剩下的时间。其中一些当然可以用于技术。显然社交媒体在其中扮演了重要角色。在同一次采访中，你被问到是什么导致了青少年抑郁、焦虑和自杀率上升。同样，我认为你的回答非常有趣且精彩。你说，简单的答案很有吸引力，但它们可能并不准确。所以我们需要对这个问题进行广泛的审视。你能详细说明一下吗？是的。
I mean, I think this is where psychologists can sometimes become so frustrated with the media because they want sound bites and pithy, you know, pithy little bits. And so, you know, it's so often, you know, you see things where it's like, it's the phones. You know, the reason it's important, it's the phones, right? And it's so easy for people to sort of bang that drum. But it's not really clear. it's the phones, right? I mean, we don't really have the data to show that. And I'm not going to say that, you know, the dawn of digital technology is a minor thing. I mean, it is a game changer
我的意思是，这就是心理学家有时会对媒体感到如此沮丧的地方，因为他们想要简短的引语和简洁的小片段。所以，你经常看到这样的事情，比如“是手机的原因”。你认为重要的原因是手机，对吧？人们很容易敲响那个鼓。但这并不真正清楚是手机的原因，对吧？我的意思是，我们并没有真正的数据来证明这一点。我并不是说数字技术的诞生是一件小事。我的意思是，这对每个人来说都是一个游戏规则的改变者。
for everybody. But it can feel to me a little dismissive, a little diminishing, not really recognizing the complexity of young people and the complexity of the environments they live in. And, you know, the APA has done fabulous surveys on, you know, what's causing stress for young people. in that recent report that you put out about stress in America. And young people worry about lots of things. They worry about school shootings. They worry about climate change. They worry about immigration and deportation, you know,
但对我来说，这感觉有点轻视，有点贬低，没有真正认识到年轻人的复杂性以及他们所处环境的复杂性。而且，美国心理学会（APA）在关于年轻人压力来源的调查中做了出色的工作，在你们发布的关于美国压力的那份最新报告中。年轻人担心很多事情。他们担心校园枪击事件。他们担心气候变化。他们担心移民和驱逐出境，你知道，
that they are nuanced, smart, paying attention, tuned in. And I think sometimes, you know, to boil it down to one thing, it just isn't fair and cannot be accurate. Yeah, there has to be more at play in what that's going on. Yeah, people are complicated. And that's why we're psychologists, because we like that about them. And so we have to sort of do the work of communicating that complexity in a way that does appeal to a broad audience that is used to pithy soundbites that are rarely accurate. I want to touch on something you mentioned earlier when you were talking about the teens being over.
他们是细致入微、聪明、关注并投入的。我认为有时，将其归结为一件事，是不公平的，也不可能是准确的。是的，在正在发生的事情中一定有更多的因素在起作用。是的，人是复杂的。这就是为什么我们是心理学家，因为我们喜欢他们这一点。所以我们必须以一种吸引习惯了简洁但很少准确的引语的广大受众的方式，来传达这种复杂性。我想谈谈你之前提到的关于青少年过度……
So can you talk about the importance of allowing for free time, unstructured time? You hear that a lot for young children, but how important is that for teenagers? Well, I love this question because there's a lot of ways to slice it. The first way we want to think about it is from the standpoint of stress. And, you know, just as psychologists, you know, we find anxiety. It's a helpful warning system that alerts you when things are amiss. You know, stress is a healthy and normal function. It's a sign that you are stretching, that you're working at the edge of your capacity.
所以你能谈谈留出空闲时间、非结构化时间的重要性吗？你经常听到这对幼儿很重要，但这对青少年有多重要？嗯，我喜欢这个问题，因为有很多切入点。我们想到的第一个切入点是压力的角度。而且，作为心理学家，我们发现焦虑是一个有用的预警系统，当事情不对劲时会提醒你。压力是一种健康且正常的机能。这是一个信号，表明你正在伸展，你正在能力的边缘工作。
It's not inherently problematic. It's got an inoculating function. We know that. But stress is only healthy if there's an opportunity for recovery. Chronic stress is not something that we're a fan of. So kids need downtime, and especially by high school, given how demanding high school is for a lot of students these days. I mean, they're very ambitious. and they do a lot, you know, if they're given the opportunity.
它本身并不成问题。它具有“接种”功能。我们知道这一点。但压力只有在有恢复机会的情况下才是健康的。慢性压力不是我们所推崇的。所以孩子需要停机时间，特别是到了高中，考虑到现在高中对许多学生来说要求有多高。我的意思是，他们非常有抱负，
We do need to think about the importance of a chance to recover. And when I look at, you know, our most ambitious, most hard-driving students, you know, right now the average number of APs being taken by kids who are applying to Ivy League level schools, they're taking eight APs in high school, which is a really huge amount. And, you know, it goes up to as much as 13 APs in high school. And the problem with this is not that the world. work is too hard or there's too much work. They can do the work. They are bright enough. They are capable enough. They have the work ethic to do the work. They can't do the work in the time they have
如果给他们机会，他们会做很多事情。我们确实需要考虑恢复机会的重要性。当我审视我们最有抱负、最努力的学生时，目前申请常春藤盟校的孩子所修的 AP 课程平均数量，他们在高中修了 8 门 AP，这是一个非常巨大的数字。而且，高中 AP 课程的数量高达 13 门。这个问题不在于工作太难或工作太多。她们能完成工作。她们足够聪明。她们足够有能力。她们有完成工作的职业道德。她们无法在拥有的时间内完成工作
available to do it unless they never rest. And that's actually where the problem rests. So it's important for there to be downtime. What's interesting to me, though, is that what constitutes downtime is highly idiosyncratic. You know, how you relax is not going to be how I relax. And so I'm also really fascinated by the wide variety of ways in which kids recover. So some kids really need to go home and watch TV for a little while or listen to music or, you know, cuddle with their dog or, you know, go for a run. You know, there's any variety of things. Other kids recover at the time. sports practice. They have a really busy intense day and then they go out and they play basketball and they get it all out and they hit their homework feeling renewed. And so it may look on paper like
除非她们从不休息。这实际上就是问题的症结所在。所以有停机时间很重要。然而，让我感兴趣的是，什么构成停机时间是非常独特的。你知道，你放松的方式不会是我放松的方式。所以我对孩子恢复精力的各种方式也非常着迷。所以有些孩子真的需要回家看一会儿电视，或者听音乐，或者拥抱她们的狗，或者去跑步。有各种各样的东西。其他孩子在体育训练时恢复精力。她们度过了非常忙碌紧张的一天，然后她们出去打篮球，把一切都释放出来，她们在做作业时感到焕然一新。所以纸面上看起来
that's a very tightly scheduled kid. She works hard at school all day. She runs right to basketball practice and then she hits her homework. That may work for her so long as there's recovery in those activities. Other kids, they're going to need to be away from people. They're going to need some downtime. And so the question of whether or not a kid is over-scheduled, I think, is very individual to the child and how quickly they recover and what for them constitutes recovery. So maybe it's helping the teen, your child, identify what makes them feel energized and where they feel depleted. Because I think that could be difficult sometimes. If you think, I enjoy basketball or I enjoy, you you know, debate club or whatever, but, you know, they might still feel drained after and need to have
那是一个日程安排非常紧凑的孩子。她整天在学校努力学习。她直接跑去参加篮球训练，然后开始做作业。只要这些活动中有恢复，这对她来说可能就有效。其他孩子，她们需要远离人群。她们需要一些停机时间。所以我认为，一个孩子是否日程安排过满，是非常因人而异的，取决于孩子恢复的速度以及什么对她们来说构成了恢复。所以也许是帮助青少年，你的孩子，识别什么让她们感到精力充沛，什么让她们感到精疲力竭。因为我认为这有时可能很困难。如果你认为，我喜欢篮球，或者我喜欢辩论社什么的，但是，她们在之后可能仍然感到精疲力竭，需要有
some quiet time. They might, right? And I think that's where, you know, we watch them and get to know what works for them and they observe themselves and get to know what works. And, you know, I think mindfulness is, you know, phenomenal and so useful and so scalable, you know, to a broad population. But mindfulness is not going to be a way to reset for everybody. You know, not everybody's going to, you know, not everybody's it's not going to float everybody's boat. And so we have to, as much as, you know, there's all this fantastic new mindfulness programming coming into schools, we also need to be careful that, you know, if a young person has a system that works really well for them, you know, I think of an example of a girl told me that when she was very, very upset, what she felt helped her most was to rip up a
一些安静的时间。她们可能会，对吧？我认为这就是我们观察她们并了解什么对她们有效的地方，她们观察自己并了解什么有效。而且，我认为正念是非常了不起的，非常有用，而且可以扩展到广泛的人群。但正念对每个人来说都不会是一种重置方式。你知道，并不是每个人都会……它不会让所有人都感到舒服。所以我们必须，尽管学校里有所有这些奇妙的新正念课程，我们也需要小心，如果一个年轻人有一个对她们非常有效的系统，我想起一个例子，一个女孩告诉我，当她非常非常难过时，她觉得最能帮助她的是撕碎一个
piece of paper into lots of little bits and then tape it back together like a puzzle. It was just so funny and so particular. But I thought, man, you know, you don't need a mindful in this practice, like, you have what works for you. You know, why should we rest that away from you and, you know, impose upon you what we think will work? Yeah, absolutely. It's like, you know, whatever works for the individual person. I wonder how this all plays into this concept that we hear often about helicopter parenting and how that affects teens, because research is shown that children with parents who are overly involved in their lives tend to have more anxiety and less satisfaction with life. So, you know, it can be, well, it can be helpful for a parent to help their teen navigate
把纸撕成许多小碎片，然后像拼图一样把它粘回去。这太有趣也太特别了。但我心想，伙计，你知道，你不需要在这种练习中保持正念，你有适合自己的方法。你知道，我们为什么要剥夺你的这种方式，强加给你我们认为有效的方法呢？是的，绝对是这样。就像，你知道，无论对个人来说什么有效就行。我很好奇这一切是如何与我们经常听到的“直升机式育儿”概念，以及它如何影响青少年联系在一起的，因为研究表明，父母过度参与生活的孩子往往会有更多的焦虑，对生活的满意度也更低。所以，你知道，父母帮助青少年应对生活可能是有帮助的，
life. Is it also helpful for the teen to find their own way and sort of figure out what works for them? Absolutely. You know, and I'm just thinking about this, you know, how do we think about it at a fairly granular level? And, and one of the things I think that often happens at home with young people is, you know, that a young person will get very upset. You know, something will have gone wrong. They'll have had a fight with a friend or they bombed a test. And they become very upset, which of course is, you know, as a parent, that's very upsetting for you too. And there can be this rush to try to address the problem quickly, right, on the part of the parent. And there can almost be, I think, sort of a communication of a sense of like your emotional upset is like a fire that we've got to put out,
但让青少年找到自己的方式，弄清楚什么对他们有效，这也有帮助吗？当然。你知道，我只是在思考这个问题，我们如何在相当细致的层面上思考它？我认为在家里与年轻人相处时经常发生的一件事是，年轻人会变得非常沮丧。你知道，事情出了差错。他们可能和朋友吵架了，或者考试考砸了。他们变得非常沮丧，当然，作为父母，这让你也非常难过。父母可能会急于迅速解决问题，对吧？而且我认为，这几乎传达了一种感觉，即你的情绪困扰就像一场必须扑灭的火，
right? Or else it's just going to get out of control and I need to make it stop right now. And the effect of the parent rushing in is that feelings remain pretty scary, I think, for young people, the sense of, you know, I'm upset. Now we've got a real crisis. And also a sense that, you know, the way that crises get solved is that somebody comes in and helps you a whole bunch. You know, they call the parent of the other kid. They, you know, hire a tutor. And what I'm interested in instead, you know, from parents who can be more restrained, right, which is not to say just letting kids hang out high and dry. But for parents who can say, you know, I can see you're very, very upset, you know, do you want some tea? You know, would it help if we just hung out together here for a little while or do you want some time alone? When parents hold back a little and don't step in in a helicopter, what young people get to discover is that emotions are very rarely like fires.
对吧？否则它就会失控，我需要立刻让它停止。父母冲进去干预的结果是，我认为年轻人会觉得情绪仍然相当可怕，那种“我很沮丧，现在我们遇到了真正的危机”的感觉。而且，他们也会觉得解决危机的方法就是有人进来帮他们一把。你知道，他们会给另一个孩子的父母打电话，或者雇个家教。相反，我感兴趣的是那些能够更加克制的父母，对吧？这并不是说让孩子们陷入困境。但对于那些能说“我看得出你非常非常难过，你想喝点茶吗？我们在这里待一会儿会有帮助吗，还是你想一个人待会儿？”的父母来说，当父母稍微退后一点，不进行直升机式干预时，年轻人就会发现情绪很少像火一样。
They're much more like waves, you know, that they rise and they crest and then they flow away. And, you know, one of the things I remember learning in my training is, you know, with a hard feeling, the only way out is through, right? You just have it. And when we create time and space for young people to discover this about how emotions work, you know, two things happen that are really important. First of all, emotions become much less frightening because you're like, oh, yeah, no, I'm having a big one. You know, let me ride it out and then I'll feel better after a good cry, right? Like, that's such a great thing for young people to learn. The other thing they learn is, it's basically an autonomous system, right? They don't need anybody else for it. And it's, I mean, it's really nice if a living person wants to sort of be there with you and be patient and quiet while you're having your moment. But what a gift, right, to model this total comfort with distress, which then helps young people feel more at ease with distress when it does occur. So at the most sort of granular level, we can rob young people of a chance to disdress. discover that humans are built in a way that we actually are pretty self-correcting or self-writing.
它们更像波浪，你知道，它们升起、达到顶峰，然后消退。你知道，我记得在培训中学到的一件事是，面对痛苦的感觉，唯一的出路就是经历它，对吧？你只需要去感受它。当我们为年轻人创造时间和空间去发现情绪是如何运作的时，两件非常重要的事情就会发生。首先，情绪变得不那么可怕了，因为你会想：“哦，是的，我正在经历一场大情绪。”你知道，让我把它经历完，大哭一场后我会感觉好些，对吧？这对于年轻人来说是件很棒的学习。他们学到的另一件事是，这基本上是一个自主系统，对吧？他们不需要任何人。如果有人愿意陪着你，在你经历情绪时保持耐心和安静，那当然很好。但能够展现出对痛苦的完全从容，这真是一份礼物，这反过来又帮助年轻人在痛苦发生时感到更加自在。所以，在最细致的层面上，我们可能会剥夺年轻人发现人类天生具有自我纠正或自我恢复能力的机会。
And then we can, of course, take that up many, many levels, you know, to if there's a problem with a teacher, you know, the parent intervening, if there's a problem with an application, the parent intervening, you know, never sort of learning how to self-correct or that in some cases there's sort of an automatic self-correction that will occur. So how can parents and families help teens embrace stress and realize the difference between unhealthy stress and healthy stress. Well, so the first thing we've got to do is even articulate that there is healthy stress and teach young people that. And I think one of the easiest way to do that is to, one of the easiest ways is to talk about stress in the same way we talk about weight lifting,
当然，我们可以把这个问题提升到很多个层面，比如如果老师有问题，父母介入；如果申请有问题，父母介入，导致他们永远学不会如何自我纠正，或者学不会在某些情况下会自动发生自我纠正。那么，父母和家庭如何帮助青少年拥抱压力，并意识到不健康压力和健康压力之间的区别呢？嗯，我们首先要做的是明确存在健康压力，并教导年轻人这一点。我认为最简单的方法之一就是像谈论举重一样谈论压力，
right, that if you want to build muscle, you have to lift weights that are heavy enough to be uncomfortable. And what happens is that when you lift weights, eventually your muscles adapt. You know, they gain strength. And what was difficult becomes easier, at which point, you know, we move you up to heavier weights. So school stress, which is a lot of stress, you know, the kids manage, is just like that. You know, when you get new material, when you get to a new grade, when you take a new hard class, at first, it's very, very stressful. It's new. It's heavier. It's harder than your used to, if you stick with it, you will soon adapt. Your capacities will expand. And you gain strength, intellectual strength, that you get to keep. And as soon as you've got it, we're going to give you
对吧？如果你想锻炼肌肉，你必须举起足够重、让你感到不舒服的重量。发生的情况是，当你举重时，你的肌肉最终会适应。你知道，它们会增强力量。困难的事情变得容易了，这时，我们就会让你增加重量。所以学校的压力，也就是孩子们管理的大量压力，就像那样。你知道，当你接触新材料、升入新年级、选修新的高难度课程时，起初，这会非常有压力。它是新的，更重，比你习惯的更难，但如果你坚持下去，你很快就会适应。你的能力会扩展。你获得了力量，那种你可以保留的智力力量。一旦你掌握了它，我们就会给你
harder work. So we can help teenagers embrace stress by acknowledging that there is such a thing as healthy stress. And though it is not pleasant, we can say, but here's the benefit, this is how you get a lot smarter. This is how you really build your intellectual capacities. And then, in terms of unhealthy stress, that's where we need to focus on recovery. Because like I said, the stress of school is doable if there's an opportunity for recovery. And so helping teenagers really know how they recover, how they like to recover, doing that, moving right to it, doing it efficiently, creating space for it can make a big difference. A few times during our conversation, we've talked about the need for parents to deal with their own anxiety. but I imagine, you know, for parents who have read your book or are listening right now,
更难的工作。所以我们可以通过承认健康压力的存在来帮助青少年拥抱压力。虽然它并不令人愉快，但我们可以说，但好处是，这就是你变得更聪明的方法。这就是你真正建立智力能力的方法。然后，就不健康压力而言，我们需要关注恢复。因为正如我所说，如果能有机会恢复，学校的压力是可以应对的。因此，帮助青少年真正了解他们如何恢复、他们喜欢如何恢复、直接去做、高效地去做、为恢复创造空间，这些都会产生很大的影响。在我们的谈话中，我们几次谈到了父母需要处理自己的焦虑，但我猜，你知道，对于那些读过你的书或正在收听的父母来说，
they might feel alarmed by these statistics and quite worried. So what advice you have to keep, for parents to keep calm so then they can then help their teen? I think parents should feel very reassured by how much power they have here, that if parents can be calm, we know from research it makes a tremendous difference in terms of the likelihood of their child. becoming unusually anxious. So the statistics are worrisome, but the news is good. There's a huge amount we can do. And, you know, then we can do it at a lot of levels over time. You know, we can help young people manage their friendships with one another. We can help them manage the romantic landscape, which is really, really anxiety-provoking for them, you know, by talking about,
他们可能会对这些统计数据感到震惊并非常担心。那么，你有什么建议让父母保持冷静，从而帮助他们的孩子呢？我认为父母应该对他们在这里拥有的力量感到非常放心，因为我们从研究中得知，如果父母能保持冷静，这对孩子变得异常焦虑的可能性有巨大的影响。所以统计数据令人担忧，但消息是好的。我们可以做很多事情。而且，你知道，随着时间的推移，我们可以在很多层面上做到这一点。你知道，我们可以帮助年轻人处理彼此之间的友谊。我们可以帮助他们管理浪漫关系，这对他们来说真的非常令人焦虑，你知道，通过谈论
you know, gendered relationships in the healthiest possible ways. We can give them strategies for managing at school and also for girls in particular, think with them about what the culture asks and equip them to be shielded a bit from some of the really unfair expectations that our culture does hold for girls and young women. So there's much, much we can do. And I really think parents should feel, you know, kind of delighted that this one is much more in their hands than they may have otherwise felt was true. Absolutely. And overall, what do you think are the most pressing challenges facing young people today, boys and girls? We ask a lot of young people today. They are, I mean, accomplishing things academically in high school that, you know,
你知道，以尽可能健康的方式处理性别关系。我们可以给他们提供在学校管理的策略，对于女孩来说，和她们一起思考文化的要求，并装备她们，使她们免受我们文化对女孩和年轻女性的一些非常不公平的期望的影响。所以我们可以做很多很多事情。我真的认为父母应该感到，你知道，很高兴，因为这件事比他们原本感觉到的更掌握在他们自己手中。当然。总的来说，你认为当今年轻人，男孩和女孩，面临的最紧迫的挑战是什么？我们今天对年轻人要求很高。他们，我的意思是，在高中取得的学术成就，你知道，
very unlike what their own parents were accomplishing. They are flooded with infant. information, they have constant access to one another, which is sometimes fun, but I think is often very tiring. I think those are all very big challenges. I think another thing I worry about is we don't talk very well about young people, that when you look at how young people are described in the media, you know, it tends to sort of fall into these kind of negative stereotypes of, you know, they're kind of naughty or they're doing the wrong thing or they're not, you know, doing what the adults want them to do. And, you know, we have the data that we are raising the best behaved generation of teenagers on record. You know, they do fewer drugs. They are delaying sex.
与他们父母当年的成就非常不同。他们被信息淹没，他们可以随时联系彼此，这有时很有趣，但我认为这通常非常令人疲惫。我认为这些都是非常大的挑战。我认为我担心的另一件事是我们对年轻人的评价不太好，当你观察媒体如何描述年轻人时，你知道，它往往会陷入那种负面的刻板印象，你知道，他们有点淘气，或者他们在做错事，或者他们没有，你知道，按照成年人的意愿去做。而且，你知道，我们有数据表明，我们正在培养有记录以来表现最好的青少年一代。你知道，他们吸毒更少。他们推迟性行为。
They, if they are having sex, they're using contraception. They drink less. You know, and there's some little blips here and there in the data, but, you know, in the broad strokes, these are really good kids. And so I actually think we should add to the stresses that teenagers face is that people don't really give them credit for how much they're accomplishing, how thoughtful they are. And we're often instead focusing on behaviors that relative to previous generations, this is a really, really good group of kids. Yeah, I think that's really fascinating. If we do give teens enough credit, you know, to obviously they need people to guide them in their lives to make good decisions, but, you know, the theme that's come up in our conversation is the fact that a lot of times
他们如果发生性行为，也会使用避孕措施。他们喝酒更少。你知道，数据中偶尔会有一些小波动，但，你知道，总的来说，这些都是非常好的孩子。所以我实际上认为我们应该补充一点，青少年面临的压力是人们并没有真正认可他们取得了多大的成就，他们有多么体贴。我们反而经常关注那些相对于前几代人来说，这群孩子其实表现得非常非常好的行为。是的，我认为这真的很迷人。如果我们确实给予青少年足够的认可，你知道，显然他们需要有人在生活中引导他们做出正确的决定，但是，你知道，我们谈话中出现的主题是，很多时候
teens can figure things out on their own or should least be given the chance to do that. And that, you know, according to those, you know, recent stats from the CDC, teens are using drugs less, drinking alcohol less, having sex less often with fewer partners. So, you said, we are raising a good generation of young people, but at the same time, We're also looking to all, you know, looking at all the things that aren't going well or the people who feel anxiety or depression or feelings of hopelessness. Yeah, do you have any more thoughts on that? I think kids live up to expectations and kids live down to them. And so we never want to gloss over real problems.
青少年可以自己解决问题，或者至少应该有机会这样做。而且，你知道，根据美国疾病控制与预防中心（CDC）的那些最新统计数据，青少年吸毒更少，饮酒更少，性行为更少，伴侣也更少。所以，你说，我们正在培养一代优秀的年轻人，但与此同时，我们也在关注所有进展不顺利的事情，或者那些感到焦虑、抑郁或绝望的人。是的，你对此还有什么想法吗？我认为孩子会达到期望，也会辜负期望。所以我们永远不想掩盖真正的问题。
And there are, you know, worrisome increases in the suicide numbers. And we need to take those very, very seriously. But I do worry how it feels to be a young person who is so plugged into the media when so often the message is that you're broken or you're not doing it right. And I wonder if there can be within that a danger of a self-fulfilling prophecy, you know, a sense that, you know, emotions can so readily be out of control. And in fact, most young people manage their emotions really very well. So I think we have to both be vigilant and take very seriously trends that, you know, are moving in the wrong direction. And at the same time, I think, you know, we know so much in psychology about how to take care of people who are suffering that I would love to think that we get our voice in there to say, yeah, you know, there are things we can do though and there's ways to prevent feeling unduly anxious. and if you do suffer with depression, we can really treat that.
而且，你知道，自杀人数确实令人担忧地增加。我们需要非常非常认真地对待这些。但我确实担心，作为一个如此沉迷于媒体的年轻人，当信息经常是你已经崩溃了或者你做得不对时，那会是什么感觉。我想知道其中是否存在自我实现预言的危险，你知道，一种感觉，你知道，情绪很容易失控。事实上，大多数年轻人处理情绪的能力非常好。所以我认为我们既要保持警惕，非常认真地对待那些正在朝着错误方向发展的趋势。同时，我认为，你知道，我们在心理学中对如何照顾受苦的人了解得非常多，我很乐意认为我们能发出声音说，是的，你知道，我们确实可以做一些事情，而且有方法可以防止感到过度的焦虑。如果你确实患有抑郁症，我们完全可以治疗它。
And to continue to advocate for all of the ways in which human beings are resilient and can be helped to be resilient, that it doesn't have to be such a dark story. I want to touch on your column a little bit for The New York Times. I mean, what are the topics that seem to get the best reception from readers? You know, it's such a funny thing. Sometimes it's a really timely topic. I wrote a piece called Parenting the Fortnite Addict. And that piece just got a ton of traction because Fortnite just came up, swallowed a whole bunch of kids before parents even knew what had happened.
并继续倡导人类具有韧性的所有方式，以及如何帮助他们变得有韧性，这不必是一个如此黑暗的故事。我想稍微谈谈你为《纽约时报》撰写的专栏。我的意思是，哪些话题似乎最受读者欢迎？你知道，这真是一件有趣的事情。有时是一个非常及时的话题。我写了一篇名为《抚养堡垒之夜成瘾者》的文章。那篇文章引起了巨大的反响，因为《堡垒之夜》刚刚出现，在父母还没意识到发生了什么之前，就吞噬了一大群孩子。
And, you know, what was so fun about that particular column, and this is my favorite part about getting to write this column, is that I got to actually unpack all of our psychological research about how video games work in terms of, you know, basically an intermittent reinforcement schedule and various other things, you know, and describe that to a general audience. But then sometimes it's the columns about really timeless issues. So other columns that I've written that have gotten a lot of traction, basically people are just desperate for any help with their teenagers. People want to connect to their teenagers. They like their teenagers. And even when their teenagers is great, that doesn't always mean their teenagers being great at home with them.
而且，你知道，那个专栏最有趣的地方，也是我最喜欢写这个专栏的部分，是我能够真正拆解我们关于电子游戏如何运作的所有心理学研究，比如，你知道，基本上是间歇性强化计划以及其他各种事情，你知道，并向大众描述这一点。但有时是关于真正永恒问题的专栏。所以我写的其他引起很大反响的专栏，基本上人们只是迫切需要任何关于青少年的帮助。人们想与他们的青少年建立联系。他们喜欢他们的青少年。即使他们的青少年很棒，那也不总是意味着他们的青少年在家里和他们相处得很好。
So, you know, in some ways it's easy to get traction with columns on teenagers. But others, you know, take up questions. Like I wrote one about why teenagers, become allergic to their parents, you know, and just that moment, you know, and often sort of 13 is the height of it where like nothing the parent does is okay. And, you know, that one, you know, just got a tremendous response. And I recently wrote one about how to give advice to a teenager. It was around the holiday time. And I think the headline was, you know, how to wrap a gift, how to wrap advice as a gift your teenager might open. Right. Because I think this is sort of one of those
所以，你知道，在某些方面，写关于青少年的专栏很容易引起反响。但其他的，你知道，会提出问题。比如我写过一篇关于为什么青少年会对父母过敏的文章，你知道，就在那一刻，你知道，通常13岁是高峰期，父母做的任何事情都不对。而且，你知道，那一篇，你知道，得到了巨大的反响。我最近写了一篇关于如何给青少年提建议的文章。那是在假期前后。我想标题是，你知道，如何包装礼物，如何把建议包装成你的青少年可能会打开的礼物。对吧。因为我认为这是那种
kind of perennial problems that parents have. You know, they've got all these really, really, you know, you know, terrific things they want to share with their teenager and they cannot seem to do it in any way that gets a satisfying response or even a response. So, you know, I really try to sort of move around in what I read about, both from the, you know, immediate concern things. So obviously I've written a fair bit about stress and anxiety to the sort of universals of family life that are difficult, but normal. and just to try to really use, you know, the training I got to make it available to a broad audience. You know, I think that that's a real thing that, you know, I'm always so grateful to see
父母面临的长期问题之一。你知道，他们有很多非常非常，你知道，很棒的事情想和他们的青少年分享，但他们似乎无法以任何能得到满意回应甚至任何回应的方式做到这一点。所以，你知道，我真的试图在我写的内容中四处走动，既从那些，你知道，紧迫的关注事项出发。所以我显然写了不少关于压力和焦虑的文章，也写了家庭生活中那些困难但正常的普遍现象。只是试图真正利用，你知道，我受到的训练，让它能被广大受众所获取。你知道，我认为这是一件真实的事情，你知道，我总是很高兴看到
psychologist writing for, you know, general audiences because, you know, we know a lot and it's not always well described by the media and we can do a good job of it. You know, I want to talk a little bit more about Fortnite briefly. It's taken the world by storm and, you know, parents seem to be struggling to keep their kids away from the game because it is a very social game. You can be on it on your phone, on a good game console, on a computer. It's really everywhere. But how can parents manage their kids gaming overall? You know, I would probably say in the same way, you know, I would start with the same advice I gave around managing technology in general. You know, first, draw lines around. what you're trying to protect. And we have these things and, you know, and doing those things, you know, sleeping, studying, being with the family, getting physical activity, you know, those will keep a kid pretty busy
心理学家为，你知道，大众写作，因为，你知道，我们了解很多，而媒体并不总是能很好地描述它，我们可以做得很好。你知道，我想简短地多谈谈《堡垒之夜》。它风靡全球，而且，你知道，父母似乎在努力让他们的孩子远离这个游戏，因为它是一个非常社交的游戏。你可以在手机上、好的游戏机上、电脑上玩它。它真的无处不在。但父母如何管理孩子的游戏总体情况呢？你知道，我可能会说，你知道，我会从我给出的关于管理技术的相同建议开始。你知道，首先，在你试图保护的事情周围划定界限。我们有这些事情，而且，你知道，做这些事情，你知道，睡觉、学习、与家人在一起、进行体育锻炼，你知道，那些会让孩子相当忙碌，
if we protect them at the levels they deserve to be protected at. And so start there, you know, so you might even, you know, just to paraphrase again, like you might say, it's not that I'm against gaming, it's that I'm for sleep, you know, so the sleep's a non-negotiable. And then I think, you know, from there it becomes very specific to family. You know, where they set limits on it. And I've seen families do a whole bunch of different things from, you know, it's only on the weekends or it's a limited amount of time per day or, you know, you have to self-regulate. And if you can't, I will.
如果我们以他们应得的水平保护它们的话。所以从那里开始，你知道，所以你甚至可能，你知道，只是为了再次转述，就像你可能会说，我不是反对游戏，我是支持睡眠，你知道，所以睡眠是不可商量的。然后我认为，你知道，从那里开始，它就变得非常具体到家庭了。你知道，他们在哪里设定限制。我看到家庭做了很多不同的事情，从，你知道，它只在周末玩，或者每天有限的时间，或者，你知道，你必须自我调节。如果你不能，我会的。
You know, I think there's a lot of different ways for parents to manage it. But we do want to see that kids have variety in their lives. You know, it's just not healthy to just do one thing all the time. And, you know, certainly there are kids who really get lost. lost in gaming. And, and, and, you know, that's a moment where the parent needs to find a way to insist on some variety in terms of how their time is spent. So all is not lost. No, no, no, no, no. Some of the articles I was reading, it seems like the pew parents are just kind of thrown up their hands or just at their width's end. I don't know what it was, but I think
你知道，我认为父母有很多不同的方式来管理它。但我们确实希望看到孩子们的生活多样化。你知道，一直只做一件事是不健康的。而且，你知道，当然有些孩子真的迷失了。迷失在游戏中。而且，而且，而且，你知道，那是父母需要找到一种方法来坚持在时间花费方面进行多样化的时刻。所以一切并没有失去。不，不，不，不，不。我读到的一些文章，看起来父母们似乎只是举手投降，或者只是到了束手无策的地步。我不知道是什么，但我认为
it's like it's important that you said just to all is not lost. There are still boundaries that can be set and, you know, maybe phrasing it in a, is it not a deprivation, but what you're gaining from limiting screen time? Absolutely. There are things that have to happen and gaming is not one of them. Well, thank you so much for joining us, Dr. DeMore. I really appreciate your time. Thank you for having me.
你说的“一切并没有失去”很重要。仍然可以设定界限，而且，你知道，也许用一种方式来表达，这不是剥夺，而是你从限制屏幕时间中获得了什么？当然。有些事情必须发生，而游戏不是其中之一。好吧，非常感谢你加入我们，德莫尔博士。我真的很感谢你的时间。谢谢你邀请我。
Great to be part of your show. If you've been a longtime listener or are new to our podcast, please consider giving us a rating at iTunes. And if you have time, write a review. We really appreciate it. Also, as I mentioned at the top of the show, we'd love to hear from you directly. So if you have any questions, comments, or ideas to share, please email me at K-Luna at APA.org. That's K-L-U-N-A-A-A-P-A-D-Rog.
很高兴能参加你的节目。如果你是我们的长期听众或者是我们播客的新听众，请考虑在iTunes上给我们评分。如果你有时间，写一篇评论。我们真的很感激。另外，正如我在节目开头提到的，我们很想直接收到你的来信。所以如果你有任何问题、评论或想法要分享，请发电子邮件给我：K-Luna@APA.org。那是K-L-U-N-A-A-A-P-A-D-R-o-g。
Speaking of Psychology is part of the APA podcast network, which includes the podcast, APA Journal's dialogue about new psychological research and progress notes about the practice of psychology. You can find all our podcasts on iTunes, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. You can also go to our website, speakingofpsychology.org, to listen to more episodes. I'm Caitlin Luna with the American Psychological Association. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《心理学谈话》是APA播客网络的一部分，其中包括播客、关于新心理学研究的APA期刊对话以及关于心理学实践的进度记录。你可以在iTunes、Stitcher或任何你获取播客的地方找到我们所有的播客。你也可以访问我们的网站speakingofpsychology.org收听更多剧集。我是凯特琳·卢纳，来自美国心理学协会。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。